right on everybody let's jump to this
first story we got timcast.com breaking
multiple members of Congress including
AOC arrested over pro-abortion
demonstration outside scotus take a look
at this year picture why aoc's hands are
behind her back looks like she's being
arrested well she was arrested but she
staged the the handcuffs she faked it
take a look at this we have this Daily
Mail circled it she pretended to be
handcuffed and you know what Daily Mail
says I love this they're like mock cops
by pretending they've been cuffed mock
the cops what does that mean why would
the cops be mocked or care about that at
all no what they're doing is people on
Twitter are seeing photos of them with
their hands behind their back and
they're going whoa they handcuffed AOC
they handcuffed ilhan Omar
people who are not paying attention will
just see photos on the news of them with
their hands behind their back as if they
were cuffed when they weren't for
dramatic effect and then AOC walks a few
feet and then like when he's out of
range of the camera she does a big Power
Fist or whatever red salute or something
like that
you know it's just so fake when they
look oh that's so fake man like you see
that picture of Bernie Sanders getting
pulled out of like he was like civil
rights activist getting arrested on the
street like it's real chaos and then
they're gonna juxtapose it with this and
be like AOC faking being handcuffed
looking badly no they think that in 20
years she's going to show this photo and
be like I fought for abortion rights
look at this picture of me it's like
when Joe Biden was arrested in South
Africa for protesting the right Nestle
in Mandela remember that that's right at
least he tells the story there's no
evidence ever happened but he was
arrested Joe Biden claims he's been
arrested like five or six times and
there's no documentation of it anywhere
but when every time he tells the story
he was arrested somewhere but you know
what I I gotta say everyone should find
themselves someone who loves them as
much as these folks love abortion like
they love when people there was the
whole talk about how you know we're not
pro-abortion we're just pro-choice now
y'all are you all love abortion I
thought you're gonna say find someone
who loves you as much as these people
love themselves well that is abortion
though isn't it
um but yeah these these folks well you
know and she has a history of fake
um photo ops right I mean that the the
white pan suit one at the Detention
Facility that turns out was a parking
lot
um is that that's actually a fake like
this it's just so hard to believe that
someone would do something so stupid but
like she went there and pretended to be
upset about something that wasn't
happening yeah or was let herself be
upset about what she was imagining in
front of her and brought her camera crew
it's so disturbable the photos and and
had a carefully chosen outfits because
you go to the desert wearing you know
white Chanel pantsuits and and yeah the
whole thing was totally staged but it
worked right because as Tim was saying
if you are a naive leftist and you think
she's a hero you just see those photos
and you say she's the best and now
they're gonna do the same with her hand
yeah you know maybe maybe I'm from
Canada and I have a different angle on
this but it seems like that couldn't
have turned out worse for her because
now there's this meme going around
Wherever Whenever anyone's crying about
like you know the they broke a nail
that's that's the picture is her cut out
white pants suit crying about it that
was wonderful look at these pictures
she's like or Terry the roller skater
from reno911 saying I was murdered
that's the other one for her it was an
empty parking lot
and she's crying this one right here
she's just so awful yeah you know the
when they write the history they could
either erase all the all the fake stuff
and be like remember when she was
protesting and got arrested and
handcuffed remember when she was crying
from us they could do that and try and
manipulate the past but if it stays
transparent it's gonna just it just
looks so bad I think to be fair like
haven't you ever been at like a big
venue or something and parking's really
hard to find and there's a big fence on
the other side there's a ton of parking
spaces you know you can't cry you just
break down you're like
going to a Cubs game in Chicago and you
got to find parking and you're driving
around you're driving around you're like
maybe sooner or later someone's gonna
move and then they don't and then you
just see that parking lot with the fence
all the way around it and you just walk
over in your white pantsuit and start
crying yeah I gotta see the 34 members
who were arrested AOC is clearly from
New York illhan Omar's from Minnesota
nothing in terms of abortion law has
changed in their state so so you can do
it we got the list here of the Democrats
who are arrested you can decry like the
national right that you think was erased
which obviously is a falsehood but but
for for Virginia where I am from for for
Maryland for California Most states
nothing has changed not only that for
many states now they're paying for
people to come to their state and have
an abortion so AOC should celebrate New
Yorkers probably having more abortion
than it did before well here's here's
the uh the crazy thing that I'm thinking
of with this stuff is
if Texas says abortion's illegal and a
man says to the to the like a man and
woman you know hook up a woman gets
pregnant where babies are made women is
eight and a half weeks pregnant I'm
sorry uh eight and a half months
pregnant and then says I'm gonna
terminate but I can do it in Colorado
not in Texas
so this is a viable baby able to survive
on its own and she flees the state
without telling me when to go to
Colorado to abort it because there's no
restrictions
this guy goes to Texas and says help
she's kidnapped my child he's viable we
could we could deliver the baby she
doesn't need to kill it but she doesn't
want it so she's going to kill it the
interesting thing is
because we talk about this a lot if a
woman did that to a baby that was two
inches
forward out of her out of her womb but
the same gestational period she'd be
hunted down for kidnapping attempted
murder but the same baby of the same
gestational period in her womb she can
drive out of state to Colorado to kill
yeah but this is crazy right now because
this is exactly how it is this could
happen right now in Texas you can't do
it in Colorado you can at eight and a
half weeks for any reason months he said
I'm sorry I said weeks ago months like
almost to the point of birth Colorado
has no restrictions what would happen
right now
if a woman did that if a woman took who
was pregnant and went to Colorado and
said I don't care a doctor could deliver
the baby and get a C-section or whatever
but you're like no no don't care if
you're doing this in Canada as well
they're calling for Americans to come
and try abortion tourism you know help
our economy because he's destroyed it so
much and yeah you can come on come on up
and in Canada I don't know if you know
this but we have zero laws I guess it's
just this the Colorado case there's no
law on it whatsoever nothing on the book
books you can kill that child up until
uh it's it's breathing air which is
shocking to I think probably to a lot of
Americans but it's shocking to any does
that happen
uh there's definitely been cases of it
yeah especially where there's not a lot
of um
especially out east
um where there's not a lot of people uh
drawing attention to the to the tragedy
of it
um you know in Alberta where I'm from
there's there's a lot of agencies that
are willing to help young mothers so
that they can actually deliver the child
and and give it a good life or even put
it up for adoption if that's what's
required required but out east a lot of
those supports don't exist because uh
it's you know abortion is second Nation
nature to Eastern Canadians I gotta
think I am not a I'm not an attorney so
those listening who are going to correct
me I have to think if in that scenario
that you raised it would be no different
and I know a baby is not drugs I know a
baby is not uh whatever I'm not I'm not
trying to make light of the pregnancy
but I have to think the rule would apply
that if there's certain States you can
smoke weed and some that you can't if I
cross the border and I smoke weed in
that state and I come back you can't say
well you did something wrong not in that
state I didn't if you can take your kid
to a a a a a a a a movie at you know
nc17 to Once data as opposed to another
and I take my state kid to Colorado when
we see a movie there we come back to
Texas and they say that's illegal well
in Texas is illegal but in Colorado it's
not I have to think there would be
nothing done to get pregnant mother no
because what happened was what whatever
ultimately happened happened in a
different state and Texas state laws
don't have jurisdiction sure and the
FEDS would have to get involved in this
where things get crazy so the woman goes
to Colorado and she terminates the
pregnancy kills the baby Texas says
that's an illegal illegal and she says
not in Colorado Colorado so what if
Colorado said you're allowed to
literally kill a person that's all of a
sudden okay like the issue is what would
happen if the woman took gave birth and
then literally grabbed the baby ran and
got in the car and just drove to
Colorado still like literally after just
delivering and she's you know whatever
like kind of messed up and hurt or
something and then gets to Colorado and
then goes to an abortion doctor who
kills the baby like it's a murder right
so what does Texas do if a person
kidnapped a child and murders it what
would Texas do contact the feds and what
if the FED says we won't intervene then
what I honestly don't know
like what what happens
they'd get away with it I mean uh
I'll just put it that way there's uh
people need to understand this about
crime in this country the feds have a
threshold I believe it's literally
called the threshold where if a federal
crime is committed but doesn't reach a
certain level they don't care like a
certain extremity of crime like uh the
way it was explained to me is federal
Securities fraud in the amount of 400
feds won't care about they're they're
not going to waste any resources over
something that small they'll ignore it
but if you're somebody who's like life
savings was stolen by someone and it was
a couple Grand the feds probably will do
nothing
as long as it was Interstate and the
states will be like we don't have
jurisdiction in that state sorry I can't
do anything about it if you legally
register for a handgun
and you happen to be the president's son
feds don't care no exactly it doesn't
matter there's degrees and there's tears
that's how it works so my my question is
Colorado
uh says it's illegal I'm sorry Texas has
at the legal Colorado says it's legal
that's a really weird circumstance
like it is a night and day difference in
Morality imagine if Indiana said you're
allowed to kill people have fun and
Illinois said you're not so a woman took
her 12 year old child to Indiana bashed
him over the head and then drove back to
Illinois and said wasn't illegal like
I'm pretty sure they're still gonna be
like we don't care you murdered them
that's why we have federal laws saying
that murders are legal no matter what
state and you could argue that maybe
there should be federal laws about
abortion just to make it easier but but
here's the issue what if the federal
government says we're not getting
involved we don't care then the states
could decide who where murder is legal
like a state could say you're allowed to
murder in our state I mean that was that
primarily what they're doing according
to conservatives Colorado is allowing
Limitless abortion at to the point of
birth yeah so like I can't let's use
Canada as an example like what if
someone drives from Wisconsin into
Canada because there's no limits and
then like at get as they're giving birth
they kill the baby
what is someone gonna do this is a
really good example because this selfie
with them this is where there is no
International resolution because it's
two different countries if the federal
government says we side with Colorado
because Biden basically has and we're
not going to intervene I wonder at what
point does Texas say
like we we need to be able to do
Expeditions essentially to to extradite
people who kidnap people and murder them
dude if another state was doing
Expeditions into my state I would fully
support the governor's removal from
power and some sort of military action
from your state from like if something
State went rogue and started invading
and attacking other states because of
their zealous beliefs I would fully
support a national and state you know
multi-state let me I mean offensive
against them let me ask you this someone
uh someone kidnaps your significant
other
and then murders her 10 miles away
across state lines
and what do you do they become federal
offense at that and the FED say we don't
carry and go out it's murder that's a
difference we don't care go away I mean
well then just justice has failed at
that stage yes literally that's what's
happening right now it's not literal
murder it's it's abortion's not murder
okay well Sheamus thinks it is
conservatives you can think things that
aren't real it doesn't make it real okay
what's the penalty if you aborted a
child in Texas now that this has changed
look what would be the penalty oh I
don't know
I think it's like trafficking abortion
or something like that yeah my point is
Ian your morality is irrelevant to the
question of legality correct if in Texas
they say it is illegal to do and the
people of Texas agree with the law that
is illegal and immoral to do and someone
commits that crime somewhere else and
the FEDS don't get involved what's the
reaction going to be do we let people
from other states literally kill our
children that's their perspective you
might not agree with it you're like not
Colorado's right they're wrong well
eventually someone's going to grab a
bunch of guns get on the back of a
motorcycle and drive in and they're
gonna go stop it's not right it's not
right and wrong like you said it's not
morality issue it's a legal issue and uh
it is the premise of of the famous Dred
Scott case I'm going to get the states
confused but the whole premise of Dred
Scott which was a terrible decision by
the courts was that
um they they took this African-American
guy Dred Scott from a a free state to a
slave state and they were like well now
that you're in this state now you're a
slave and he was like no I'm not I'm
actually from Wisconsin they were like
well you're in Missouri now and now
you're a slave and he's like but I'm not
a slave and the courts decided Well you
are this the states the state's
jurisdiction were greater than it
doesn't matter what in Illinois or
Wisconsin you were free you're not free
here Dred Scott said that descendants of
Africa had no rights to citizenship
citizenship so it was way worse than
just oh no but I mean like but the
premise of it was the this person's this
person's stature status depended upon
what state he lived in yeah the states
although the courts ultimately decided
that the states had the jurisdiction to
change his stature of course it was a
terrible decision but it's the same
about this unborn baby is the does the
baby's stature of Life viability of life
does its its Persona depend upon the
state maybe but that's not what I'm
bringing up I don't think it's relevant
I'll ask you this Ian do you believe
that Sheamus thinks abortion is murder
well he's told me that he thinks it is
so I gotta take him with his word there
all right okay so uh let's just ignore
the context around it and say someone
kidnapped Sheamus's child and is trying
to murder it what do you think he would
do to stop that murder from taking place
I don't know this is this is this is
what I mean like I don't see a a a like
I don't see a good outcome to the fact
that you have States like where there
are people who are literally like it is
murder and I will not allow it Louisiana
tried to come that's homicide but that's
that's zealous like it's not murder
legally so for you to say well I think
it is like sorry buddy you know take a
take a lot take a step in line like wait
you know it's not murder I'm looking
into Political Politico article right
now they say Texas has a trigger ban so
anyone who performs induces or attempts
abortion is guilty of a second degree
felony if the fetus survives and first
degree felony if not a first three
felony is punishable by life what's that
what's that what's the title of the
statute like what's the violation what's
the criminal violation
just says first degree felony I'm not
sure what that is and I I'm not so I
guess the crime would be the crime of
abortion yeah yeah which is after like
14 weeks I don't know what Texas's
number is but no I think Texas is period
anyone who performs induces or attempts
abortion which would be
I guess we have to look up under what
statute does it fall because I'm curious
if it falls under a murder statute
Louisiana tried to codify it as homicide
they backed off so Ian when you say it's
not murder well right legally I would
argue it doesn't fall under homicide and
they're trying to do that regardless
though if people don't care about the
distinction between the word murder and
the word abortion and they view it the
same way you saying it's not is
completely irrelevant to what the law of
Texas in Oklahoma it's just another it
sounds like an argument towards
post-modernism like well if I believe it
then that's my truth and so that's real
like sorry guys in Texas though it's
obviously considered a very serious
crime and and there's serious crimes
that I would you know I think a lot of
people would go to Great Lengths to
prevent not just murder yeah you know
right dismemberment of a limb or any
sort of rape or abuse or child abuse
people would step in and violently
protect their I mean another another way
to question it is some states the age of
consent is 16 in some states it's 18.
you how do states handle it if a person
takes a 16 year old across state lines
to a state with a low range of consent
when you come back you go to jail you
get charged now I guess the question is
will Illinois do anything to go to
Indiana to rescue the minor if the feds
won't
I have to I'd have to look into the into
the history of the law I wonder if
anybody knows we'll go this way uh a 16
year old who is a minor in one state is
taken by a 25 year old to a neighboring
state with a lower age of consent and
they say we're never coming back what
will that other state do like not in
this state it's legal in your state it's
not they're like well you kidnapped a
minor from our state even though it's
legal in that state and that's that's
possible like some states actually have
those differences if the feds don't get
involved do you think the parents of the
16 year old are going to be like guess
our kids kidnapped yeah or do you think
they're gonna be like hell in high water
I am getting my kid back if the kid
actually got kidnapped if the kid went
of its own volition it doesn't have the
authority miners can't consent
so then it would be a federal crime if
someone took a 16 year old across the
feds said it's not a crime in that you
know we're not doing it we're not
involved If the Fed said we will not
intervene do you think the people of the
state where the kid was taken from we'll
just sit back and be like oh that sucks
or do you think they're going to be like
please help me save my child they were
kidnapped like I'm saying
these these circumstances could happen
in some capacity already they probably
will they may they probably already have
yeah and so I'm sure people will
probably have a bunch of
um references they may bring up I'm
wondering like where we go here because
what's happening now is illegal abortion
and legal abortion are so legally
distinct and like Stark night and day in
Texas it is a legal period in Colorado
there is no restriction at all it is so
different that like
you've got a very serious crime that the
feds will not intervene in because
there's no federal statute on it so what
happens when a person flees the state
with enough with pregnant with a child
of a man who doesn't want the child to
be killed and then the child is killed
in another state that allows it like
there's no federal involvement because
there's no federal statute so what
happens the person just can't come back
to Texas well then is Texas going to be
like well if people start fleeing the
state and killing the the children of
these men we will do nothing about it
you're going to get a it the system
can't sustain itself that way it's just
I don't know what happens at that point
it's pretty rough I kind of put myself
in the mind of that guy like a dad who's
got an eight and a half month old baby
in gestation and the woman that wants to
bring the baby to term and raise it the
mom's like no I don't want a baby to get
Dad's like well they're divorcing maybe
the guy's like I'll raise it I want this
is my son I want it and the mom's like
no I'm gonna go kill it the guy is no no
right to stop her like grab her by the
shoulder you know you can't he might in
Texas they might might I don't know if
they have a right to do it like legal to
prevent her from committing a crime or
something because he says leaving state
lines isn't a crime after that this is
it's this is crazy territory man it is
because imagine imagine the woman's not
going to get abortion and the guy is
just like Yang leaving me so he calls a
place and says she's trying to leave to
get an abortion like a red flag law
right I don't know how you deal with
with this with a circumstance that's why
that's why Roe v Wade I thought was made
sense is because you can't leave it to
the states to figure out where where
murder where killing is going to be fine
can I just walk over there and kill him
then if I can't do it over here like
that's why we had this blanket rule of
like no you just can't or or yes you can
no you can't but it wasn't it wasn't the
Roe v Wade was like States can't decide
whether it's already decided for you
know within a certain amount of time and
then Casey changed into viability which
made it nebulous which resulted in a
bunch of States having different periods
yeah so it was totally different people
would be like in my State's 11 weeks and
your State's 15 so I'll just drive
across state lines same problem wrote
the uh the Overture jobs resulted in
them saying you need to codify at the
federal level through Congress to figure
this out which they don't have so now
we're in really dangerous territory
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast IRL come hang out live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm Eastern Time
Super Chat will even answer some of your
questions if you want to check out the
after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up Monday through Thursday at 11
PM they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time